THOSE ARE MY THOUGHTS AT THE END
OF DAY 28, AMERICA IN SHUTDOWN.
JOINING ME NOW IS OHIO CON
WHISMAN JIM JORDAN AND NEW YORK
CONGRESSMAN LEE ZELDIN.
CONGRESSMAN JORDAN, LET’S START
WITH YOU.
LOOKS LIKE STENY HOYER IS SAYING
THAT MAY 4TH WILL BE ONE Y’ALL
ARE CALLED BACK INTO SESSION FOR
REAL AS THE COUNTRY IS
BLEEDING JOBS.
OBVIOUSLY CONTINUING LOSS OF
LIFE BUT THINGS SEEM TO BE
STABILIZING AND MOST OF THE
COUNTRY.
WHY NO CONGRESSIONAL, ON-THE-JOB
MOVEMENT HERE WHILE THE COUNTRY
IS IN SUCH PERIL?
>> YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT, LAURA.
WE GOT ALL THESE TASKS FORCE AND
THEY’RE DOING GREAT WORK BUT THE
TASK FORCE THAT IS SUPPOSED TO
BE FOCUSED ON DOING A PEOPLE’S
WORK IS THE UNITED STATES
CONGRESS AND THE 50 GENERAL
ASSEMBLIES IN THE RESPECTIVE
STATES, THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
MEETING, TAKING CARE OF BUSINESS
IN LEADING BY EXAMPLE.
WE CAN BE HAVING HEARINGS.
WE CAN SIT EVERY OTHER CHAIR.
WE CAN BE TALKING THE PEOPLE’S
BUSINESS, SO WHY WON’T
NANCY PELOSI QUIT CRITICIZING
THE PRESIDENT AND TELL US WHAT
HER PLAN IS FOR BRINGING
CONGRESS BACK INTO SESSION SO WE
CAN LEAD BY EXAMPLE AND DO THE
PEOPLE’S WORK?
SO I’M ALL FOR THAT.
MY GUESS IS LOTS OF MY
COLLEAGUES OR FOR THAT BUT WE
HAVEN’T HEARD ANYTHING FROM
SPEAKER PELOSI AND MR. HOYER
OTHER THAN THEY ARE NOW SAYING
WE ARE NOT COMING BACK UNTIL MAY
>> Laura: I WOULD CONSIDER THE
FREEDOM CAUCUS AND ALL THE OTHER
REPUBLICANS ON CAPITOL HILL JUST
TO COME BACK.
JUST TO COME BACK.
YOU CAN GO INTO YOUR OFFICES,
YOU CAN HOLD PRESS CONFERENCES.
CONGRESSMAN, CONGRESSMAN JORDAN
JUST MENTIONED SPEAKER PELOSI.
SHE’S NOWHERE TO BE SEEN.
SPECIFIC HEIGHTS, SAN FRANCISCO,
NAPA VALLEY -- I DON’T KNOW
WHERE SHE IS BURIED BUT SHE’S
WAILING ON PRESIDENT TRUMP.
POLITICO REPORTING THAT PELOSI
SHARPLY CRITICIZED TRUMP’S
HANDLING OF THE CORONAVIRUS
OUTBREAK TELLING DEMOCRATS I
GUESS ON A CALL THAT IT WAS
"ALMOST SINFUL HOW THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS FAILED TO
LIVE UP TO PROMISES TO MAKE
TESTING AVAILABLE TO ALL
AMERICANS AND QUICKLY AND DOWN
AND MASK SHORTAGES ET CETERA
ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
IF THIS IS ALMOST SINFUL,
CONGRESSMAN, WHAT ABOUT A
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE, WHEN
AMERICANS ARE DYING AND PEOPLE
IN SMALL BUSINESSES SAY THEIR
DYING -- CONGRESS IS NOT IN
SESSION AND SHE’S APPARENT NOT
GOING TO PASS A SHUTDOWN
MANDATED VIA LEGISLATION.
>> THE PAYCHECK PROTECTION
PROGRAM, THAT FUND IS GOING TO
RUN OUT OF MONEY.
SHE LOOKS AT THIS AS LEVERAGE TO
BE ABLE TO GET UNRELATED
PRIORITY ITEMS AS SHE TRIED THE
LAST TIME WITH PHASE THREE, THE
GREEN NEW DEAL, BALLOT
HARVESTING AND OTHER ITEMS.
$25 MILLION FOR THE KENNEDY
CENTER, $350 MILLION FOR THE
REFUGEE ASSISTANCE.
THAT ACTUALLY MADE ITS WAY INTO
THE BILL.
SHE REALLY LIKES THE WAY THAT
GAVEL FEELS IN HER HAND, SO FOR
HER, SHE DOESN’T LOOK AT THIS AS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE BIPARTISAN
OR NONPARTISAN CARRIED SHE JUST
WANTS TO EXPAND HER MAJORITY,
SHE WANTS TO TAKE OUT THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
AND, REGARDLESS OF THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR AMERICANS THAT
NEED CONGRESS TO WORK, SHE’S
JUST GOING TO DO WHAT’S BEST IN
HER OWN POLITICAL INTERESTS AND
BY THE WAY SHE HAS PEOPLE
RANK-AND-FILE IN HER OWN
CONFERENCE.
THERE ARE PEOPLE I TALK TO THAT
THEY WOULD ACTUALLY LIKE TO WORK
WITH US, WORK WITH THE PRESIDENT
TO GET GOOD THINGS DONE BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THE LEADER OF
THEIR PARTY DOESN’T HAVE THAT
SAME GOAL.
>> Laura: CONGRESSMAN JORDAN,
JOE BIDEN, THEY ACKNOWLEDGE THE
CRISIS BUT THEY SEE A POLITICAL
OPPORTUNITY, WHICH HAS TO BE
EXPOSED EVERY STEP OF THE WAY.
THIS IS WHAT HE SAID ON USING
THIS FOR CLIMATE CHANGE,
CONGRESSMAN, WATCH.
>> THE UNITED STATES HAS NO
CHOICE BUT TO SEIZE THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND CREATE MILLIONS,
MILLIONS OF GREAT PAYING JOBS
THAT YOUR ENERGY PLAN HAS
SUGGESTED AND MINE AS WELL.
ENERGY AND STRUCTURE OF
TOMORROW.
WE TAKE A BACKSEAT TO NO ONE
WHEN IT COMES TO FIGHTING
CLIMATE CHANGE.
>> Laura: WE HAVE TO SEIZE ON
THIS VIRUS IS A POLITICAL
OPPORTUNITY.
IMAGINE IF THE PRESIDENT SAID
THAT.
WE NEED TO SEIZE ON THIS VIRUS
AS AN OPPORTUNITY TO, YOU
KNOW -- ANYTHING.
TAKE ON CHINA, FUND THE WALL.
THEY JUMP ALL OVER HIM, AND THEY
DO.
>> TWO THINGS THE DEMOCRATS
NEVER MISSED, THE LEFT NEVER
MISSES, THEY NEVER MISS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ADVANCE THE LEFT
ONE CRAZY AGENDA.
THEY NEVER MISS AN OPPORTUNITY
TO ATTACK THE PRESIDENT.
THEY STARTED ATTACKING THE
PRESIDENT BEFORE HE WAS EVEN
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
THOSE OF THE TWO THINGS YOU CAN
ALWAYS COUNT ON CONSISTENTLY
FROM THE LEFT BUT THE THING THAT
SCARES ME MOST, LAURA, IS WHAT
WE ARE SEEING HAPPENED TO CIVIL
LIBERTIES, FUNDAMENTAL FREEDOM.
THE GOVERNOR OF KENTUCKY SAYS
HE’S GOING TO ARREST PEOPLE AT
CHURCH.
WE HAD A PROSECUTOR IN ONE OF
OUR COUNTIES SAY HE WAS GOING TO
CHARGE PEOPLE FOR FELONIES IF
THEY WEREN’T -- IF THEY WERE
VIOLATING THE SHELTER AT HOME.
EVEN SAID IF HE WAS GOVERNOR HE
WOULD CALL OFF THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO STOP PEOPLE
FROM GOING TO CHURCH ON SUNDAY.
WE GOT GOOGLE SAYING THEY WILL
TRACK AND GIVE THAT INFORMATION
TO THE GOVERNMENT AND THE
SCARIEST THING OF ALL -- THE
SCARIEST THING OF ALL IS
GARCETTI, THE MAYOR OF
LOS ANGELES SAID IF PEOPLE
SNATCH THEY WILL BE REWARDED.
>> Laura: I DID THAT TWO WEEKS
AGO.
>> ALL THIS HAPPENS AT THE SAME
TIME THAT MICHAEL HOROWITZ IS
TELLING US WHEN HE LOOKED AT THE
29 PFIZER APPLICATIONS, EVERY
SINGLE ONE OF THEM HAD PROBLEMS
WHEN THEY WERE SPYING, LOOKING
TO GO SPY ON THE AMERICAN
CITIZENS.
THAT’S THE CONTEXT THAT SCARES
ME THE MOST AND THAT’S WHY
CONGRESS SHOULD ALSO BE BACK AT
WORK, DEFENDING CIVIL LIBERTIES
AND LEADING BY EXAMPLE DOING THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE.
>> Laura: I WANT TO STAND UP
AND APPLAUD THAT.
WE ARE THINKING OF TRACKING
AMERICANS WHO HAVE -- HAVING
SOME DATABASE, WHICH ULTIMATELY
COULD LEAD TO CONTACT TRACY.
SOME OF IT SOUNDS MAY BE
PLAUSIBLE WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
TO REOPEN THE COUNTRY, ACCORDING
TO SOME OF THE EXPERTS, WE NEED
TO TEST 6-7 MILLION PEOPLE IN
THESE VARIOUS TESTS PER WEEK.
I THINK WE ARE DOING, WHAT,
200,000?
IS THAT RIGHT?
CORRECT ME IF I’M WRONG.
BUT WE HAVE TO SET METRICS FOR
REOPENING THE COUNTRY THAT ARE
REALISTIC, NOT CONTINUING TO
MOVE THE GOALPOST ON ONE
AMERICANS CAN ACTUALLY EXERCISE
THEIR CIVIL LIBERTIES AND MAKE A
DECENT DARN LIVING.
>> OUR ECONOMY WAS THE STRONGEST
IT’S EVER BEEN BEFORE THIS
HAPPEN.
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES AT RECORD
LOWS.
WE HAD OUR MARKETS AT RECORD
HIGHS AND THEY ALL CAME TO A
SCREECHING HALT BECAUSE THIS
VIRUS THAT QUICKLY SPREAD ALL
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
I’M ALL FOR REOPENING OUR
ECONOMY SMARTLY.
THAT MEANS WE DON’T WANT TO SEE
ANOTHER OUTBREAK.
A PART OF THAT IS INCLUDING
RAMPING UP RAPID TESTING,
RAMPING UP ANTIBODY TESTING TO
BE ABLE TO BE SLICK AT A
VACCINE --
>> Laura: I GOT TO JUMP IN ON
THIS.
WE’VE GOT TO GO IN A SECOND.
I AGREE WITH YOU IN AN IDEAL
WORLD WHERE WE DON’T ACTUALLY
HAVE TO PAY BILLS AND SMALL
BUSINESSES DON’T HAVE TO LIKE
PAY RENT.
HAVING SIX OR 7 MILLION TESTS --
MAYBE WE CAN DO ALL THAT.
MAYBE MY THINKING ON THIS IS
WRONG.
MAYBE.
BUT IT HAS TO BE REALISTIC AND
ACHIEVABLE FOR A VIRUS THAT ENDS
UP -- MORTALITY RATE WILL END UP
BEING ABOUT 55, 60,000,
HORRIBLE, BUT CERTAINLY NOT
2.2 MILLION AND THEN WE ARE
GOING TO THEN KEEP AMERICA
CLOSED UNTIL WE HAVE 7 MILLION
TESTS A DAY OR A WEEK OR
WHATEVER THE HECK THE NEW NUMBER
IS?
I MEAN, THAT’S.
PEOPLE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT THAT.
THINK ABOUT WHETHER IT’S EVEN
ACHIEVABLE BEFORE ELECTION DAY I
SHOULD SAY.
FINAL THOUGHT, COMMERCE
MAJORITY, REAL QUICK.
QUICK.
>> GEOGRAPHY SHOULD DEFINITELY
BE PART OF THIS.
I COME FROM SUFFOLK COUNTY
NEW YORK WHERE WE HAVE OVER
21.5000 CORONAVIRUS CASES.
BRINGING BACK THE ECONOMY IN A
PLACE LIKE MINE MIGHT BE
DIFFERENT THAN SOME OTHER PARTS
OF THE COUNTRY THERE HAVE BEEN
LESS AFFECTED.
>> Laura: YOU’RE RIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT.
IT’S INCREDIBLY HARD HIT THERE
AND IT’S DIFFERENT FROM NEBRASKA
OR EVEN OHIO.